hello how's it going but I hide from you
how are you I'm good
nice to talk to you so sure what's that
I said what an absolute pleasure and
just thanks thanks for giving the
opportunity to me oh you're welcome
buddy so what's going on there buddy
and basically my situation as I said on
Facebook is I'm quite new to all this
I'm a first year junior doctor I'm 23
and I've just come out straight out of
medical school and I'm working in
Liverpool and basically I've decided
that I liked his property I came across
yourself online on YouTube and Reggie
book I've really likely to this prophecy
thing ago I'm pretty motivated but my
problem is I'm sought I'm extremely time
corps as a junior doctor I'm in sort of
70 grams worth of debt and basically
understand that sort of cash flows my
biggest issue at the moment and I've
decided personally to educate myself
really I'm going going courses and
really sort of think about rent to rent
in ways that I can first firstly sort of
free up some cash flow for myself first
that that's the main that's the main
sort term goal with the with a long term
goal being really to supplement my wage
so I can have a bit more time to spend
with family and stuff all right all
right cool so so currently you said
you're 70,000 pounds worth in debt
you're working as it as a junior doctor
and are you living in Liverpool yeah I
refer my live in Liverpool win it in a
flat just not too far from centre town I
share it with friends okay so what's
your plan then how are you want how much
income do you need in order to you say
did you say about three or four K to
become sort of financially free so to
speak yeah yeah really about 20 24 24 30
I mean I do enjoy my job listen and I
think when they sort of get through the
first two years as being a junior doctor
and I'm gonna have a little great
another little break on my third year
where I've actually I can have some more
time to sort build up some more money
and things because it's a bit more free
in the third year but I want to sort of
supplement on a long way so it's 24 plus
really would be yeah with people it's
almost almost double my way show me you
do not buy the time but you
you can't quite a bit money is a junior
there's just the money's traded flowers
and a lot of them really yeah how many
hours are you doing at the moment as a
junior doctor shutting down anywhere
between sort of fifty to seventy two a
week sometimes you can do four to six
hour week I'm all night this week so I'm
doing today every day and so I thought I
got out of bed for this one to throw it
in it was an important one to me so I
thought you know what what can I change
this alright and what's your salary my
family currently is about 36 I've only
had two ways pockets so far and that's
sort of paying off my own my name is
wrap from my sort of student accounts a
handsome overdraft or up to a bit grand
or so far and which is sort of my
property scout that I knew it's all 0%
interest up yeah yeah so what do you
want to start what do you want to be
doing in ten years when you're 33 when
I'm 33
hopefully obviously I'll be a GP
part-time and with us off a full-time
property portfolio including sort of
HMOs and rents rents really and I really
I really enjoyed so I think I really
enjoyed HMOs anyway I used to help
landlords when I was at university saw
all their houses for them okay I mean
usually used to get the admin fees off
themselves I've spoken to a few in
Liverpool but as you can imagine we've
been time for it so it's all went off
towards the end my medical school
thought and the grace you like but it
was really helpful but then okay what
why why do you want why do you want to
build a property portfolio though if you
want to be a doctor and you really enjoy
that and there's good money in that and
you actually enjoy it why do you want
also ton property but earlier I think it
was sort of last year I realized that to
me even though I do enjoy a medicine and
life is about more than that and there's
other things I want to do and then when
you meet most doctors there and their
source
you know the comfortable that they're
really sort of time restricted if you
like mmm so I think absolutely that
still like to be a GP while my interns
so I've got free time to spend with
friends and family
I mean I'm only that'll probably
extremely quite a lot through middle
school and I just know that so have time
to spend with em and pain
holidays and things just freed up that's
really yeah time more than cash I
understand as a GP Afghan quite a bit
but it's the time that's thought yeah
more important to me really don't make
sense so so for you then is the property
game is this like a three six month plan
is it a three six year plan I mean when
you want to see results and start
getting income from property thinking
long-term are we thinking more
short-term or both one of these sort of
all backs in the past with things when I
was at uni was sort of patients and I
know property is a long-term game and
I've tried to slow myself down a bit
this time I know that I'm really good at
sauce I'm really good at usually sort of
finding fun fun and deals and things get
any contact of people with some interest
in things but you know it's I know it's
a long-term game and I'd really like to
earn this time really gain the education
that I need before sort of jumping into
it but obviously there comes a point
where you've had enough education you
really just need to get handed and dirty
I'm not sure I'm at that point yet but I
think I've seen a bit of a push really
of you know just just just getting into
something getting into it I mean
obviously the team and surrounding
myself with people that do do it every
day absolutely sort to bring me on leaps
and bounds yeah so a short time I love
this you know I love that I mean I mean
by the end of this year I'd quite like
to move out of this flat and then borrow
some money or family or friends to have
my own house and retsoor ran out to
friends just to figure out cash flows so
that short term yeah
but then I'm really motivated thought
about to have long-term properties that
could sauce capital growth and it's
obviously a massive thing but also I
know the cash flow in the meantime is
just just as important really sucking
sort of keep my head above in the
positive really yeah and so what what do
you want from me just just some advice
really something I mean I've followed
your story on YouTube and a Reggie Burke
and you like me you really inspired me I
was just wondering saw me being so time
poor at the moment I mean obviously up
is a bit of an obstacle
you know the amount of hours I work and
I am prepared to sort of take time off
to do courses and things I think that's
really important and I understand that I
need to invest time but if there's any
sort of any advice you'd give me that
was taught me to be the most time
efficient as possible Britain but will
it be taught and you might feel sourcing
or if you've got anything else you think
that sort of worth having for my plan
well I think there's a few things that
you could be and should be doing I mean
the fact that your base in Liverpool is
really cool because a lot of people live
in areas that aren't really very good
for investing and they have to drive six
hours each way to get to a place such as
Liverpool where is this on your doorstep
so I think that that's that's a real
thing that you got going for you second
thing you've got going for you is that
you are switched on you manage take
cellos before you've worked with
landlords
you know the craic I think you've got a
lot going for you I think the things
that you need to bear in mind is if
you've not got money to invest so you
need to do strategies such as sourcing
and rent to rents and stuff that's fine
but if you've not got money and you've
not got time then there needs to be
something you know you need to put
something in so I know that you're
willing and you're hungry and stuff but
you know it's not gonna happen Connor
for you away actually don't you need to
make sacrifice to make it happen so so
what I'll probably what I would probably
say in regards to what strategy to use I
probably do three things I do number one
I think it'd be really good if you've
got a couple of rent to rents in
Liverpool you could do service you could
do like find a couple of apartments or
do them as low rent to serviced
accommodation yeah now you don't have to
spend loads of time like literally some
of the guys some of the guys that I'm
working with that they'll they'll take a
week or two off work and in that week or
two they'll go and secure two or three
deals yeah so it's not like all you need
to work really hard for six months you
know literally it's just a case of maybe
a few a few days you know maybe making
some calls viewing some properties if
you if you find some apartments in
Liverpool that are in the right part a
Liverpool that you can rent for say five
and six hundred quid
and you can get permission to rent them
out on on serviced accommodation get a
company like a VEVO to manage the the
apartment and you you can rake it in you
can break it in doing that and
Liverpool's of cracking area for that
well yeah but you could you know you can
do that I mean yeah you know you're
reasonably switched-on you're in the
right area so I think that'd be one
strategy second strategy that I'd use
alongside went to rent would be I would
be sourcing deals so any property it
doesn't work for you let's say you find
a ready to rent deal but you need to
invest ten grand into it and it's like
and then you need to furnish any it just
really stuck up for you then then I'll
be then I'd be then going on Facebook
group so I've been finding Facebook
groups where they allow you to talk
about deals that you've gotta not be
selling the deals I mean one deal a
month sell one day a month to three
brands it's like a full time income
that's correct if it's just a lead like
oh I've got I've got a potential deal
I've just found it then yeah you know
you might charge a few hundred quid but
if you can package it up you could even
I know you're time poor but you could
even like put a little Power Team
together in Liverpool and then package
it up with the team and you know really
go to town on it and although he's gonna
have to work quite hard cuz you're
working full time as it is it's short
term it is short term pain for long-term
gains delayed gratification along side
all this stuff that you're doing in
Liverpool I would be putting aside a
portion of your income inside and saving
I don't know you saving money every
month yeah yeah yeah I'm trying to save
sort between 750 mm Quinn if I found I
mean yeah it's quite a bit I'm all about
sort of two and a half a month roughly
so I'm trying to stay in a lot of ground
if I can and obviously the first two
months just paying back my overdraft but
then after that I'll be going into the
plus and if the other thing I didn't
tell you actually then I know my like my
mum and dad and have literally got about
a hundred odd chasing in the band
they're so retired about 16 retiring you
always wants to do property my worry is
that should should they sort of learn
that some of that to me I really you
know because it's family I really want
to saw make sure I'm confident with it
something hit the outer a return they
want something Junction I don't want to
recommend miss around someone so close
to me yeah all right tell your mom and
dad that you've got a brilliant idea and
that you're really confident you can
invest that money really well but before
you even talk about doing it you want to
get some deals to yourself first yeah
so don't let them spend it or invest if
anybody else get yourself a couple of
wrapped events in Liverpool source a
couple of properties Liverpool to other
investors and get some money and then
your confidence will be through the roof
your knowledge will be through the roof
your have some savings yourself and
you'll be thinking right and then borrow
the hundred grand off your parents and
buy a couple of big courses are great as
long as they give you a return on
investment when you invest in a property
you want to see you you need to see a
return on investment in the same way
when you're investing in a course you
need to see a return on investment yeah
so hopefully it might my programs are
understands off renter in principle but
hey I don't have a power team in place I
need to do that and I guess any way to
do that sort of network or and going
courses so you know I guess of course is
probably understand you know I'm trying
to get to one you're doing a promise let
me take some of that yeah I mean courses
obviously off I wouldn't run training
programs if I didn't think they were
good when you just go and do it and go
and get the deals suddenly the power
team just come into place suddenly
they've got the correct contracts just
come into place you can spend a long
time learning and planning but when you
just do things much come into place so
what will happen is you'll find a ready
to render in your
my goodness I've got this rent to rent
deal it doesn't work for me so I need to
sell it on and then you'll be thinking
you know what it's worth me taking two
days my time to go and spend two days in
a room filled of 200 investors because
not only will alone but I know that all
also flog a deal and went to your aunt
yeah because you're going you're going
with actual questions with actual deals
to term a reviewed with properties to
sell because you've done it so I
wouldn't delay the doing before the
learning especially if you're not in
risking anything if you're about to
invest you know 100 grand into something
then I'd say go get education first but
of yourself I think you just got to
start doing also in regards to your
finance with your finances you said
about you're gonna try you know you're
using words like I'm gonna try and save
a thousand pounds a month and see what I
can do
most people they spend all their money
on bills and different things and then
they save and invest what's left but
when you do that there's always nothing
so what you need to do is at the foot
when you get paid straight away boom you
need to put a thousand pounds whatever
it might be a side into a different
account that's locked or whether you
can't touch and then yeah the rest you
pay your bills and everything like that
second where you pay yourself first yeah
and then what will happen is
miraculously the bills will take care of
themself but also you'll be saving and
that way come six twelve months you will
have enough money to buy your first
little property you can you know buy it
to live in and rent the rooms out and by
that time you'll have experience you'll
have money to invest in your own
property you'll have some went to rent
deals you'll have sourced a few
properties and then you'll be in a
position where you can borrow the money
off your folks see instead of saying I'm
going to go around the shops and buy
some clothes and go for Mackey's say
Saturday I'm going to spend three or
four hours going to view in five or six
potential investment properties and then
when you're doing it you'll start to get
really good questions and instead of
looking for all the answers you want to
start looking for the right questions
and obviously you know area dependence
or service coordination attention in the
pool yeah exactly yeah in service
accommodation oh yeah absolutely I'll be
I'll be wanting to do that in Liverpool
he's running to know she need for me
right now which is the right kinda
question that's the right kind of
question that oh my gosh I've got this
rent to rent deal what do I do with it
that would be a brilliant problem to
have yeah so yes instead of having a
problem at the moment your problem is
all I've got time I'm frustrated or
that's a terrible problem yeah the
problem you want is uh what order this
went to rent you always gonna have
problems but you want the right corner
problems very welcome bro take it easy
keep you posted
[Music]